Space is unbelievably strange.
You would be forgiven for thinking that every
planet out there is similar, just a big ball
of rock and gas, but planets are remarkably
more unique than that.
Here's the top 10 strangest planets in the
known universe, that seem like they belong
in some bizarre science fiction series.
First up is this dark, menacing planet affectionately
named TrES-2b.
It is located 750 light years away from our
solar system.
As far as we know it is officially the darkest
planet in the entire universe.
It reflects less than 1% of all light that
hits it, making it significantly darker than
the majority of known exoplanets.
It's ominously dark surface can be partially
explained by the light absorbent gasses that
make up the bulk of the planet.
But scientists don't really know for sure
why it is so dark.
But it gets creepier, not only does this evil
looking ball of gas not reflect any light,
it actually glows a molten red colour, as
if it's a hot ball of coal on a fire.
The surface of the planet is a punishing 1,100
degrees Celsius, which is so hot that it glows
red.
This next planet is anything but dark.
In fact it sparkles luminescently in space,
just like a diamond.
Because, well, it is in fact a gigantic diamond.
Yes that's right this planet named 55 Cancri
e is about twice the size of earth and a third
of it is made up of solid diamond.
The planet is very carbon heavy, and the planet
is so dense that all carbon is in the form
of solid diamond.
But don't get too excited, the diamond planet
is located a spectacular 40 light years away
from Earth.
And even if you could travel that far and
retrieve the endless supply of diamonds it
has to offer.
There is so much diamond on the planet that
bringing even a minute fraction of it back
to Earth, would completely overwhelm the diamond
supply and therefore make diamonds completely
worthless.
So this beautiful planet is best admired from
afar.
This next planet seems to defy everything
you thought you knew about chemistry, because
it's a giant ball of ice, on fire.
Imagine for a second you're on the ice planet
Hoth from Star Wars.
That's exactly what Gliese 436 b would look
like except that the icy surface is constantly
burning at 439 degrees Celsius.
So how can this be?
How can ice defy the laws of chemistry and
stay completely solid at 439 degrees above
its melting point?
Well, the planet's gravity is so immensely
strong that it pulls the melted ice water
towards its core, compressing it into a solid
form, stopping it from ever evaporating, no
matter how much it burns.
Next time you complain about the weather on
Earth, just stop for a moment and be thankful
that you don't live on the planet HD 189773b,
where it constantly rains glass, sideways.
This planet's atmosphere is full of silicon
particles which give it it's beautiful blue
colour.
But because of the planet's extremely high
surface temperatures these silicon particles
condense to form solid glass which flies around
the planet sideways in it's endless 4,000
mph winds.
But hey, at least it's not as bad as living
on WASP-12b.
This poor unfortunate planet is slowly being
eaten alive by its star.
It's caught up in an orbit so close to its
star that the whole planet has been heated
up to unimaginably high temperatures and its
mass is slowly being sucked up as it hurtles
around the star extremely fast.
The planet which is roughly the size of Jupiter,
however it appears to be larger because the
molten temperatures of its parent star have
caused WASP-12b to balloon up.
This poor planet loses an incredible 6 billion
metric tonnes of mass per second.
In fact it's being torn apart so quickly that
it's no longer a sphere, but an egg-like,
oblong shape.
Next up is Gliese 581 c.
This planet is very special because it's been
voted by the scientific community as one of
the top three exoplanets likely to support
alien life.
However its very different to Earth.
It orbits a red dwarf star so if you looked
up into the sky it would always be a deep
crimson red colour.
The planet is also tidal locked, which means
it doesn't rotate on its axis, just like our
moon's relationship to Earth, one side of
the planet is always facing away from its
star and the other always facing towards it.
The side of Gliese 581 c that is always facing
its red dwarf star is so blisteringly hot
that if you were to stand there it would melt
you alive.
However the opposite side of the planet, facing
away from the star is so cold that you would
instantly freeze.
So you may be wondering, how could this extremely
violent planet possibly support life similar
to humans?
Well there is a narrow strip of land, halfway
between its hot side and its icy side that
is just the perfect temperature to support
life.
But be careful not to take a step on the wrong
side or you will most certainly be toast.
In 2008 we sent a message from Earth directly
at Gliese 581 c and it is expected to reach
the planet in 2029.
Next up is a planet in the Scorpius constellation
known as WASP-17b.
What makes this giant of a planet so peculiar
is its shear size.
It is 1.9 times the size of Jupiter, which
is the largest planet in our solar system.
It's so large that theoretically it should
not exist.
According to scientists it breaks the laws
of how large a planet can actually get.
For its size it also has an extremely low
density.
Because of this it fits in to a very unique
class of planets called puffy planets, yes
that's actually a scientific term.
Puffy planets are planets with an extremely
large radius and a very low density for their
size.
But that's not all that makes WASP-17b so
strange.
It also has a retrograde orbit, which means
it rotates in an opposite direction to its
host star.
You may remember that Luke Skywalker's home
planet of Tatooine in Star Wars had two suns.
But, as is often the case, real life can be
much more amazing than science fiction.
149 light-years from Earth is a planet with
not one, not two, but three suns.
This three star planet, which goes by its
catalogue name of HD 188753 Ab, sits within
the triple star system HD 188753.
If you could live on this planet you would
experience triple shadows, and constant eclipses
as its threes parent stars cross each other's
paths.
And of course you would see the some of the
strangest and most beautiful sunsets and sunrises
in the universe.
Now imagine you're in the middle of the Pacific
Ocean, the sky is blue with fluffy white clouds
but there's no land to be seen, in every direction
you turn is just endless water.
Well, that's exactly what it would be like
if you were to visit this planet 47 light
years away from Earth, which goes by its catalogue
name of GJ 1214b.
That's because its made up entirely of water,
many scientists have nicknamed this planet
the waterworld.
The entire surface of the planet is one giant,
continuous ocean, and it remains the exactly
the same for miles underneath the surface,
until eventually you hit the planet's core,
which is made of solid ice.
But this isn't any ordinary ice, its not the
kind of ice you would find in your freezer.
Because this ice isn't frozen due to cold
temperatures.
The water in the planet's core is under such
immense levels of pressure from the surface
that the core has been compressed into solid
ice.
This is a very special form of ice known to
scientists as ice VII (ice seven).
And last but not least.
470 light years away is a planet discovered
by the Kepler space observatory, known as
Kepler 438b.
This planet is very strange, not because it
has any extreme features, but quite the opposite.
Because it is, to date, the most Earth-like
planet we have ever found.
The Earth Similarity Index is a standard measure
of how similar to Earth another planet is.
With a score of 1 being identical to Earth
in every way, and 0 being nothing like Earth.
Kepler-438b boasts an impressive Earth Similarity
Index of 0.88.
Making Kepler 438b super rare, and very special.
Discovered in January 2015, this planet has
all the right pre-requisites for alien life.
Most importantly it is a rocky world, like
Earth and its proximity to its host star puts
it in what scientists call the goldilocks
zone, which is the holy grail of space exploration.
The goldilocks zone is when a planet is not
too close to its parent star that it's too
hot for life, yet not too far away that it's
too cold.
Water is essential to life, where's there's
water, there's probably life, but in order
to have complex life there has to be liquid
water, which most of the time can only occur
in the goldilocks zone.
So Kepler 438b, a rocky planet in the goldilocks
zone is highly likely to have liquid water,
and therefore life.
Which makes it one of the strangest and most
interesting exoplanets we have ever discovered.
Thanks for the view, subscribe for more Thoughty2.